pop
[Musique]
ce soir sur le divan d'henri chapier
maria pacôme
né à paris le 18 juillet 1923 elle est
la fille d'un militant communiste qui
sera déporté pendant la période de
l'occupation autres épreuves tragiques
l'exécution de son frère résistant par
les allemands il fut le premier à croire
à la vocation théâtrale de marjah c'est
à partir de ce moment qu'elle décide de
remporter une victoire sur le destin en
montant sur les planches vous et selon
rené simon a joué andromaque elle
triomphe en 58 dans oscar avec jean paul
belmondo et pierre mondy
elle y reviendra en 71 avec louis de
funès mais ce monstre sacré du théâtre
de boulevard
non contente d'être une actrice de génie
écrit et joue ses propres pièces
débordante de vitalité
elle propulse eu son appétit des bons
mots et sa joie de vivre aussi bien au
cinéma qu'à la télévision
c'est ce que l'on appelle de nos jours
un exceptionnel pouvoir de communication
à l'âge de sept ans j'étais une petite
fille très timide
j'ai été élevé d'une manière assez rude
avec un père extrêmement sévère et juste
je pense
j'estime est juste une fille timide avec
d'avec ddd élan par moments avec sur
mettait en confiance de fonds s'est
littéralement femme est resté d'ailleurs
vous avez parlé d'un père sévère et dans
la biographie on lit qu'il était
militant communiste
oui c'est ça oui oui c'était un militant
communiste un pur un superbe d'ailleurs
il a assez payé
oui mais il avait il avait une grande
halle était très pour lui l'éducation de
ses enfants c'est très important
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il a très bien
fait parce qu'il m'en est resté plein de
choses de il avait une délicatesse en
même temps mais il exigeait une extrême
courtoisie
oui ça correspondait bien d'ailleurs à
ce qu'il était et puis vous êtes
beaucoup déplacé la famille s'est
déplacé lui même aussi alors est-ce que
c'est dû à ses missions politiquement et
se dément pas non non absolument pas
papa commencer il avait un garage et
puis après l'été il est arrêté en tant
que communiste au moment du régime
daladier et à ce moment là quand il est
revenu des camps puisque c'est avec une
valve il est il a acheté un taxi c'était
très difficile d'ailleurs pour pouvoir
trouver l'argent pour ce taxi y est il a
fait le taxi mais c'était pas du tout on
voyage parce que je suis de biarritz
enfin il était de biarritz alors y avait
plein de pas comme à biarritz ensuite il
avait ouvert un petit garage à agent les
pins alors j'étais lever un petit peu
aussi à juan-les-pins oui on a beaucoup
circulé et alors on parle peu dans ses
biographies souvent de votre mère est ce
que l était également orienté vers la
politique tragico va bien ah non non pas
du tout je trouve qu'elle a été très
agacé même nous aussi mon frère et moi
on est un peu agacé c'est beaucoup plus
tard qu'on a compris tout ce qu'ils
avaient donné qu'on toute cette
sincérité mais quand on est un homme
comme lui n'aurait peut-être pas dû se
marier avoir des enfants c'est très dur
quand on donne tout à la politique
quand on accepte cette fois cet idéal
pourtant il a dû être très heureuse
d'avoir un fils qui lui est allé
jusqu'au bout de l'engagement puisque il
a été même
hélas fusillés par les allemands en être
heureux bien sûr temps venant des camps
qu'il l'a su et j'évite toujours d'en
parler de ça c'est une période qui était
très très dure et dont à moi vous
souffert dans quel alors vous les papas
bien sûr de sam en fait il était
tellement nous considérions un petit peu
comme responsable de tout ça voilà
suivre on n'en parle plus gênant
simplement votre vocation et surtout vos
grands décision est intervenue à ce
moment là j'étais forcé de l'évoquer
parce que c'est un peu le rapport fait
ça c'est parce que oui voilà ce qui
s'est passé c'est que papa nous nous
élevons d'une manière extrêmement sévère
on était très très surveillée et
certains quand il a été arrêté
j'étais vraiment encore une enfant
presque mais déjà je vous rapprocher de
la jeune fille et j'ai eu envie d'une
certaine liberté
j'en ai trop profité d'ailleurs j'ai une
jeunesse très très très turbulente et
alors il parie que la danse vous
attentez peut-être même avant le thé
alors oui oui j'étais passionné
dangereux est une bonne danseuse
d'ailleurs les jambes trop courtes
puis j'ai pas suffisamment de te courage
faut un courage extraordinaire être
comédienne n'est rien à côté de la
discipline qui exige la danse mais je
suis né sur les pointes vraiment parce
qu'à biarritz on était toujours en
espadrilles et j'ai c'est un sage c'est
un don je fais encore d'ailleurs
maintenant de temps en temps comme ça va
me la mettre sur les pointes avec mes
espadrilles mais j'aurais pas été une
bonne dans ce jeu regrette pas
[Musique]
j'étais à l'école commerciale je me
souviens j'ai toujours aimé toute façon
j'avais toujours un côté un petit peu la
comédie m'attirait beaucoup le théâtre
mais nous ne sortions pas beaucoup hein
et puis je me souviens d'un d'un poème
qui s'appelait la mort du cheval de
victor hugo
il trouvera le papa à chaque occasion il
avait trouvé un jour j'avais donné ce
poème comme ça en famille et chaque fois
kevin hill communion un baptême
une cérémonie qu'elle confie que je dise
la mort du cheval de victor hugo
j'ai prise en grippe depuis supporter la
mort du cheval jabeur victor hugo mais
plus la mort du cheval
mais professionnellement le premier
contact ça a été avec rené simon le
fameux qu'au relais si oui oui j'avais
vu comme je voulais un petit peu j'avais
été je travaillais pour finalement
puisque papa n'était pas la maman est
obligé de travailler et donc j'étais
apprenti dans un magasin de chaussures
et j'avais vu un journal que il y avait
un cours de théâtre g pourquoi pas aller
voir et j'ai été voir rené simon qui
était d'ailleurs très très chic avec moi
très chic parce que je suis resté
pendant un mois j'ai payé le premier
mois et puis après je pouvais plus
j'étais le voir j'existe pas parce que
c'est trop cher mais tu restes tu engel
intéressante
cependant lui vous imaginez entre
absolument le drame c'est fou mais
d'ailleurs fait c'est normal quand on
quand on mange dans ma tête j'ai pas on
n'a pas envie d'éclater de rire si on me
voit à priori j'ai plutôt un visage
comme ça un peu marqué alors j'ai
toujours eu cette tête là d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que j'ai eu une carrière
tellement tardive c'est qu'elle a
commencé vraiment mon emploi ça a été
dépassé 30 ans avant j'ai jamais été
jamais une tête de jeune fille était
très bien mais en fait c'est le premier
rôle et jeu
vu la reine et les à sion ou la maison
c'est est méconnaissable
j'étais j'avais les cheveux tirés en
arrière jette une pauvre femme quittée
qui a été violée dans la montagne me
souviens que la jouer avec edwige
feuillère etais s'etait j'ai alors là si
vous m'aviez vu cette époque j'étais
terrorisée par edwige qui est pourtant
absolument délicieuse mais moi je jouais
avec edwige bage été ma première pièce
la première fois que je jouais à paris
je n'avais jamais joué
jamais je restais ma première pièce oui
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
oscar c'est venu presque à la fin de
cette année là oui oui oui non voilà ça
s'est passé très rapidement en vue d'y
après la renier les insurgés pensez
vraiment que on l'a vu je sais même pas
si on a parlé moi dans l'écriture je
crois pas ça l'appareil ça n'a pas été
ce que j'espérais mois gibbons du moment
qu'on joue à paris que j'ai un rôle
important
on va se précipiter et puis on va me
téléphoner rien mais vraiment secteu
marester l'époque où il y avait il ya
vait catherine célèbre souvenait maria
casarès qui a à cette époque ont fait
était là est encore la grande comédienne
kelly mais enfin elle était très très
elle jouait beaucoup donc j'avais pas de
place là elle était prise déjà ces
places là je me suis impatiente et parce
que vraiment mon plus gros défaut c'est
la patience dijoux bon assez comme ça ne
rien faire et comme j'avais les amis qui
étaient au canada qui me dit qu'on
pouvait travailler au canada
j'ai précisé avec un pass pour des
migrantes d'ailleurs moi je fais jamais
les choses à moitié
je suis parti jouer à moi à montréal est
à montréal comment donner là la
possibilité
j'ai joué tout de suite j'ai tout pris
tout de suite parc à vélo j'ai de la
chance il y avait le directeur du tas de
rideau vert qui était venu quelques mois
avant à paris il avait vu deux pièces
dont la mienne
donc pour lui j'étais vraiment déjà une
comédienne qui avait été un peu connu à
paris alors j'ai joué monsieur de falun
d'or et c'est sur un télégramme de
j'avais un agent oui tu vas voir l'agent
ce moment là qui m'a dit m'a dit on
passe des auditions pour oscar j'ai pris
vraiment choisi un nom au canada et j'ai
pris mon billet d'avion pour venir
passer une audition pour oscar et à
partir de là mon l'étiquette la dengue
[Musique]
mais alors le comico au théâtre comme au
cinéma en général on croyait à toc c'est
est l'apanage des hommes moi j'ai le
sentiment que pour ça a été comme un
défi prouver le contraire prouvé que les
temps avaient changé et que vraiment le
comique
c'était aussi un très grand rush de
charme où vais je pense quand même
qu'avant moi il y avait quand même
il y avait déjà d'ailleurs au moment où
j'ai commencé jacqueline maillan qui
était déjà qu'ils étaient déjà tête de
la fiche sur wii et qui est une sacré
comique mais moi je ne me considère pas
du tout que me bon je crois que c'est
plus qu'on appelle une fantaisiste si
vous nous donnez un terme qu'une j'ai
pas une comique vraiment j'ai pas
l'impression
puis j'aime je dis souvent ça on a quand
on commence à jouer on n'a jamais envie
de faire rire c'est drôle d'ailleurs
comme la jeunesse et est un peu
nostalgique on a envie d'émouvoir les
foules
on n'a pas envie de faire rire et c'est
parce que dans la vie et je fais rire un
peu mes amis quand j'ai pensé que
peut-être je pouvais le faire sur scène
et mais j'ai j'ai pas souffert des
pièces que je jouais jamais eu honte de
ce que j'ai joué j'ai jamais joué deux
pièces vulgaire jamais joué de
chefs-d'oeuvre non plus mais j'ai pas
honte
simplement je très bien gagner ma vie ça
m'a fait démarrer et c'est sans doute
pour ça que j'ai eu envie de
j'ai eu envie de vous donner un petit
peu autre chose ce que j'ai en moi quoi
un peu plus de tendresse un petit peu
plus de nuances que c'était un ennemi
qui passait à à 150 à l'heure sur une
scène avec en plus j'avais ça on comme
une soul ou silhouettes qu'on dit plutôt
agréable je tombe bien les robes alors
sa lecture est bien habillé et falaise
j'étais un peu esclave de super ça j'en
pouvais plus de ce personnage mais
justement c'est pour ça que vous avez
écrit oui même savent où il met ce que
vous avez écrit
est ce que vous jouez n'est pas sans
rapport avec ce que vous dans la vie -
va bien chez lancée mais bien
de la femme moderne de de ce qu'elle est
devenue de ce qu'elle deviendra sa vie
et jeunesse épanouie et oui bien sûr on
bien sûr d'abord comme suit une sacrée
paresseuse quand j'ai commencé à écrire
j'ai pas fait tellement d'efforts
j'écris comme je parle un peu c'est
peut-être ça qui fait que ça a plu c'est
que bon je vais pas plus loin je ne
lance pas de message si je pouvais je
ferai un aucune raison mais je ne m'en
sens pas tellement capa joie parce que
je peux mais j'ai mon petit univers à
moi j'ai envie de de trimballer comme ça
sur scène mais c'est tonique parce que
c'est une façon d'être c'est une façon
d'être tout le temps et je essentielle
dans la vie
oui oui je le sors avec le public je
sens parce qu on est on joue avec le
public aussi et je vois bien comment je
suis accueilli sur scène très bien ils
sont contents de nous retrouver et quand
ils m'attendent quentinois sont contents
de dire vous êtes là même
[Musique]
ça
j'ai jamais fait beaucoup d'efforts
c'est une espèce d'injustice a que ceux
qui veulent que les jeunes qui veulent
faire quelque chose ne m'écoute pas trop
parce que dans ce métier il faut
beaucoup de travail et il faut
effectivement allé voir les gens faut se
déplacer mais il ya aussi une question
de destin qui a dû jouer pour moi en ce
sens que j'ai jamais rien fait pour
et c'est arrivé quand même mais j'ai un
cas un attention parce que je suis
horriblement timide et chaque fois que
j'ai dû tenter une petite démarche ça a
marché mais ça c'est je dis bien si le
destin c'est terriblement injuste 1
c'est comme le physique c'est injuste
aussi la présence on l'a où on l'a
passera rien avant avec le talent ça cc
c'est fou ça je connais des comédiennes
les comédiens qui ont beaucoup de talent
et qui n'ont pas de présence
si si c'est bizarre ça mais alors
justement cette attitude est ce qu'elle
vous pose pas un problème par exemple
par rapport à votre cinéma fils oui est
ce que lui voue l'exhorté à agir
davantage que vous apprend de lui ses
dimensions je sois ici là je crois qu'il
va très très bien se débrouiller
françois il est plus cohérent que moi il
est plus il a un humour fou mais tout ça
est très maîtrisé
il est assez formidable boscus de la
maman qui parle qui est en train de
bêtifier sur son petit 1
je vois tes le filet et je ne
l'influencent absolument pas et je
m'aperçois il ay la voilà encore une
chose qui était il n'a pas travaillé du
tout françois il était alors usé de la
la la pub il était était dessin dessinée
admirablement il a eu envie de jouer ce
petit rôle dans ma pièce et personne ne
le croit on dit mais c'est pas possible
a pris des cours pas du tout il a ce don
de parler nature con mais quelquefois
des années avant d'obtenir sa ce
naturelle innée il l'a il a aussi cette
présence il est pas spécialement beau
chat charme fou parce qu'on me l'a dit
hein c'est pas moi mais alors il les
montées sur scène un peu par hasard une
impulsion alduy ou à cause de votre
carrière
pas du tout je pensais pas une seconde
que françois un jour en avant vu d'abord
parce que souvent on en parlait très peu
entre nous de ta en tout cas de cette
possibilité jamais et il ne s'occupait
pas tellement de ma carrière
totalement je ne pense pas d'ailleurs sa
comédienne préférée est loin de là non
il a fait un constat comme ça et puis un
jour il disait quand même et pièces
avant je donnais à lire j'aimais bien
son avis trouve déjà mais débordant de
compliments des enfants il donnait son
avis et là j'en avais un peu assez
d'être dans la pub depuis déjà après
deux ans et il m'a dit ce petit truc là
ce petit rôle à moi mais tant que je
pourrai jouer j'étais suffoquer jeudi
mais tu m'as toujours dit françois que
tu pourrais jamais être un trac fou
monter sur scène guy non mais depuis
j'ai sauté en parachute je crois plus
rien ne peut me faire peur et c'est vrai
il avait sauté en parachute quelques
mois avant et il a eu très peur tu l'as
vu certainement travers mais qu'est-ce
qui se maîtrisent bien le gamin à
personne ne l'a vue donc hors sol pour
vous j'ai l'impression que la profession
de verre débattre difficile pas du tout
absolument pas non j'en ai levé un autre
aussi enfin et à christophe aussi
christophe qui fait partie de la grande
maison de de ballainvilliers il ya plein
de jeunes qui sont autour de moi comme
ça
non nous avons eu je n'ai pas comment
dire complicité c'est pas compliqué je
devrais dire avec françois nous avons
une complicité d'humour
nous nous aimons rire ensemble je pense
que si quelque chose de très très très
grave au jeu bien sûr il m'en parlerait
mais il ya une grande pudeur aussi une
grande liberté réciproque et c'est
peut-être une des choses que je croise
les j'ai bien réussi françois
l'éducation de françois mais ça encore
parce que j'ai pas une difficulté c'est
un garçon ça va bien ça y est j'ai pas
eu de difficultés ou de drogues ou de
nom mais ça peut arriver ça aussi un bon
voilà tout a été un peu facile
voyez-vous le début de ma carrière a été
difficile la vie a été très dur et
maintenant c'est dommage j'aurais bien
me fixer maintenant et plus bouger vous
plus vieillir ne plus parce que c'est
bien là maintenant là ça va ça va
[Musique]